[Applause]
and finally new rule you're not going to
win the battle for the 21st century if
you are
a silly people and americans are a silly
people
that's the classic phrase from lawrence
of arabia when lawrence tells his
bedouin allies that as long as they stay
a bunch of squabbling tribes
they will remain a silly people well
we're the silly people now
you know who doesn't care that there's a
stereotype of a chinese man in a dr
seuss book
china all 1.4 billion of them could give
a crouching tiger flying
[ __ ]
[Applause]
because they're not a silly people if
anything they are as serious as a prison
fight
look we all know china does bad stuff
they break promises about hong kong
autonomy they put uyghurs in camps and
punish dissent and we don't want to be
that but
it's got to be something between
authoritarian government that tells
everyone what to do
and a representative government that
can't do anything at
all
in two generations china has built 500
entire cities from scratch
moved the majority of their huge
population from poverty to the middle
class
and mostly cornered the market in 5g and
pharmaceuticals
oh when they bought africa
their new silk road initiative is the
biggest infrastructure project in
history
indebting not just that continent but
large parts of asia europe and the
middle east to the people who built
their roads bridges and ports
if you want to go anywhere in the world
these days you better have a yen for
travel
for travel oh stop it
in china alone they have 40 000
kilometers of high-speed rail
america has none
our fastest train is the tram that goes
around the zoo
california wanted to build high-speed
rail connecting the
entire state but alas could not we're
six billion in the hole just trying to
finish the track connecting the vital
hubs of bakersfield and merced
one small step for nobody one giant leap
if you're a raisin
[Applause]
on a national level we've been having
infrastructure week
every week since 2009 but we never do
anything
half the country is having a
never-ending woke competition deciding
whether mr potato head has a dick
and the other half believes we have to
stop the lizard people because they're
eating babies
we are a silly people even when we all
agree on something
like getting rid of the penny no
the inertia the ass covering the graft
the lawyers the cowardice
nothing ever moves in this impacted
colon of a country
we see a problem and we ignore it lie
about it fight about it endlessly
litigate it
sunset closet kick it down the road and
then write a bill
where a half-assed solution doesn't kick
in for 10 years
china
china sees a problem and they fix it
they build a dam
we debate what to rename it
that's why their airports look like this
and ours look like this
in san francisco it took 10 years just
to get two
bus lines through environmental review
the big dig
a tunnel in boston took 16 years
and don't get me started on my solar
hookup
china once put up a 57-story skyscraper
in 19 days
they demolished and rebuilt the san yuan
bridge in beijing in 43 hours
we binge watch they binge build
when kovet hit wuhan the city built a
quarantine center with 4 000 rooms in 10
days
and they barely had to use it because
they quickly arrested the spread of the
disease
they were back to throwing raves in
swimming pools
well we were stuck at home surfing the
dark web for black market charming
we're not losing to china we lost the
returns just haven't all come in yet
they made robots that check a kid's
temperature and got their asses back in
school
most of our kids are still pretending to
take zoom classes while they watch
tick-tock
and their brain cells slowly commit
ritual suicide
as george bush once said is our children
learning
there's a progressive trend now to
sacrifice merit for equity colleges are
chucking the s.a.t and a.c.t
test and in new york mayor de blasio
announced merit would no longer decide
who gets into the schools for advanced
learners
but rather a lottery system you think
china's doing that
letting political correctness get in the
way of nurturing their best and
brightest
you think chinese colleges are offering
courses in
the philosophy of star trek the
sociology of seinfeld
and surviving the coming zombie
apocalypse
those are real and so is china and they
are eating our lunch
and believe me in an hour they'll
they'll be hungry again
you